oh this week we've got rat cafe rise of
Robocop and proud porn dad
take it away kisses let's hear the first
one I'm ready I knew you're gonna love
this one I love it already
so there is this tourist attraction in
San Francisco called the San Francisco
dungeon have you guys heard of it hmm
it's near the war I've heard of a
dungeon gym sauna Cisco it's like an
hour-long ride where they walk you
through these different themes and they
have actors there where they're
reenacting like suburbs of ghost history
oh cool it seems like a really cool
attraction actually I want to visit it
our actors human direct human it's all
free so they're partnering up with a Bay
Area rat rescue group and Oh rabbit yep
yeah well would eat our favorite I don't
know people just have it in their hearts
to say that it's like a makalah roaches
but I don't like rats that are like in
your house now that are in the walls or
you mean like yeah another go rats the
feeder pet rats that are going to be my
snake rat I don't know they just come
domesticated rat oh they're both feet
are rats now they're not feeder feeder
rats are there more sickly but there's a
specific breed of rat that the rat
breathe yeah the pet message was not
research rat it's not [ __ ] bookmaker
oh it's not make holes in your home rat
you try to say holes in your home oh
yeah okay [ __ ] this up
what is that maze rat research rat holes
in your home rat nests to survive
granted you a rat yeah what about the
that's it rats the pet rats teacher rat
had a [ __ ] dribble basketball rat hmm
that's it yeah that would be the center
part so there's a mighty good teaching
tricks and they're really smart and
they're really cute and clean today
clean this attraction they're having
this pop-up cafe for only two days in
July
and pretty much the tickets cost $50 or
$49.99 it includes like a drink so
either coffee tea or water and then you
can spend 15 minutes with these
ambassador reps down so the only image I
have to show you guys your emotional
image Oh God hey Mac springtime any
humor me
yeah like rat you know what that's my
birth animal rat a year of the rat
mm-hmm they're really that means you're
really smart you know how people dock
the tails of copper spaniels for medical
purposes yes I'm pretty sure that the
same people should do this but if they
dr. tiller a rat I love their tail but
they do freak them out that's a majority
that's what freaks people out
why because it looks like a worm snake
skin it's just like this little dead
like no fur thing like if they dot the
tail of it what am i what am I going to
spin them with I don't have a dad how do
I make rat nunchucks after work that's
what freaks people out it has like this
little nub that one is kind of cute
because I've heard it multiply I'm going
to see its face or its eating they're
like yeah it's so cute in the neck above
the tail Oh like I see their little ears
and they clean it like this I love that
they go like this and then they do this
because they're always if you touch them
they feel like home around 30 so they
start cleaning them so cases to go like
this it's so [ __ ] cute [ __ ] off me
thriller yes yes play with them I put
them away okay cause I got a shower this
very kind of he really upset about that
though I do change it it was like what
the [ __ ] you're a rat [ __ ] okay you
know what else I'm a sucker you're gonna
treat me like that
[ __ ] these guys so I have their cool ass
rat cage and then I have like paper on
the floor
shredded paper and then I have like this
little hole making their house and if
I'm looking at them for two moment they
start pushing the paper that they can
make a wall so that I can't do this yeah
like what the [ __ ] is wrong but I pay
for this [ __ ] I want to look at you so I
move it and then I got my glasses make
some funk away
and I keep pushing it like that's what
I'm saying like you guys bothering me
yeah it's like Rafael the kind of like
are you serious like God needy much
wrong they start building a paper wall
give us some privacy you know we didn't
agree with Ludwig's office Oh haven't
you mem you don't go now Carla how cute
though would you guys be done and visit
this thing yeah I'm down to is a
canister service engine I personally
don't have a problem with rats as a pet
in general so can I just have a problem
with the wild ones that carry stuff like
leptospirosis yeah you know that rat
lungworm rats are born with zero
diseases how'd they get so many disease
I think because of they're in a wild and
they eat a bunch of [ __ ] and yeah well
that's what I'm saying like I'm talking
with those [ __ ] man my parasite
[ __ ]
I thought I got parasites in Hawaii cuz
I drank the water on accident recently
yeah when I was on Maui you know that's
like a waterfall I like to swim in I was
like ah and then the waterfall pressure
was so strong that you went oh don't
show so much water look like the [ __ ]
gravity man wasn't thinking about the
gravity oh my god and then I don't
swallow you can just spit it out nobody
goes to strong strong yeah whatever you
go straight into your mouth cuz I'll
like ah like this is a [ __ ] water
this way ah I know for Street why you
didn't drown yeah God dad yeah I wish I
could see no swimming like this going
glad you didn't drown oh yeah that [ __ ]
was crazy I didn't know the waterfall
water was going to [ __ ] me up like that
it's time for our next story the world's
first operational Robocop Oh a Larry
doom ah it looks so scary are you
[ __ ] serious yeah a robotic police
officer yeah
Robocop oh my god every bit of here it
looks so scary you can't reason with
them I know that's why but it looks
scary yes it's the same one I'm thinking
of it was a really tall one right what
is he just like me
made it comes up and he gives tickets to
cars that's been at the meter too long
is expired yeah because I wouldn't want
this guy coming in doing house raids and
stuff they're saying that it has like a
built-in tablet on its chest so then
people can use it to pay their fines or
to report any crimes and they can also
transmit and receive messages from the
police station you can't beat up any
criminals no yes
oh it's not a con file it is creepy so
it's mainly like an ATM with like pretty
much they're like oh no no it's not that
way this is pretty creepy they look like
they're Jason good murder he looks like
a like a Japanese police jabbawockee
let me since Anthony is the police
helmet we saw a bunch of police officers
with those like hats in Japan so I want
to play this video and you guys will see
it in action you know it's not the same
robot it's as I would report crime on an
iPod iPad like that it's just going to
take too long and also do like a salute
he's too slow he agrees yeah this isn't
impressed me Dan this is a [ __ ] robot
no it doesn't person either because it's
on wheels the one I saw actually walks
independently like Robocop yeah I was
really scary
you're the cop I didn't read it but I
saw it and it looked like a cop damn it
or research it's not exactly whoa I try
not to read articles because I know
we're going to do it all on the canyon
if I see a picture that my cool we're
probably gonna do it us I don't know
should ever send it over so then I could
see that's just kind of whacked I agree
I want to see a robot with a gun yep or
some [ __ ] that can like rappel
from the ceiling do it you wouldn't be
scared though but I don't want it to
happen well I'm a good guy so what am I
scared of I'm scared he might like you
never know that's why I got [ __ ] gun
did you not watch minority reject but
he's going to be made out of [ __ ]
titanium and [ __ ] and you can't shoot
them and get rid of them titanium is
really light you could probably shoot on
but they're really strong I also got a
shotgun yeah blow that [ __ ] away
that'd be even crazier what is even the
robots on spatial processing that'd be
[ __ ] TV program man somehow that's
why it's lied
cuz it's programmable they don't even
program it like it's just like naturally
they're like it is racially profiling
people copying on the floor you're
Chinese [ __ ]
yeah the program to say that what are
you talking about hey aunt I'm Mexican
like well Robocop really just set the
standard really high for us I think the
hot hood just was like whatever comes
out if you're not as good as Robocop
you're not [ __ ] dull but Robocop's a
different story because that was
actually a seemingly human being Murphy
yeah it had like you've been brain
inside it in everything that's true I
have emotions my kids you know [ __ ] like
that when he took off his helmet [ __ ]
freaking cold yeah well you're really
ugly put that [ __ ] back on it was
[ __ ] receding hairline like [ __ ]
just wires coming on his [ __ ] yeah it
was pretty gross the helmet back the
remake of robocop was a huge
disappointment but all these remakes are
[ __ ] pissing me off you know why--i
was a huge disappointment
number one story wasn't great than the
beach there was a club cg stuff feel
amazing however it's not rated R you
can't do Robbo complicated and easy like
the old Robocop that [ __ ] was crazy for
the straight killer because I watched
no club as a kid and it was on public
television so all the stuff that was
pretty crazy wasn't even on there and
then I saw the one on VHS and this
[ __ ]
blasted yeah they edit it they edit that
on TV yeah he was just like blood
exploding everywhere else was like [ __ ]
I got freaked out because I didn't know
that part exists I love that
so yeah that's when he was gay and the
villain is actually Aaron Foreman's
father in that 70 show I am
yeah he's the villain oh yeah yeah Eddie
philosophy like ah it was crazy bloody
oh yeah I haven't seen it yo you should
watch Robocop those watch it what Isaac
don't watch history I want an actual
replica of the Robocop gun it was like
this big that [ __ ] was gangster though
it comes out of the leg - it was so
tight but I holster there's a
straight-up automatic weapon through any
so accurate what they yeah do you think
the way technology is advancing so
quickly you think we'll see something
like that cyborg oh yeah why not already
happening and then like them just taking
over all of like the public service jobs
and stuff hmm maybe works like I said
does it looks a lot higher the whole
world is pretty excited about this
because like what it's really happening
now like this is real in reality because
and starting to watch the streets of
Dubai I know really reality though you
have this message I'll be saying the
people who excited about you are excited
it's kind of like being excited about
voicemail oh you're telling me we could
leave message in Tomba [ __ ]
foster people yeah remember when I came
out everyone was like that yeah I think
I remember that yeah it was that was the
same reaction yeah but this isn't
amazing though I think we have other
technologies that blow the [ __ ] out the
water
yeah amazing you know what's dope though
is that drone taxi that Dubai has that
[ __ ] blew my mind that's I'm sure
they're dolls cool I just feel like this
[ __ ] give I robots really good time
too [ __ ] up yeah and that's all I'm
here I think people are gonna [ __ ]
die get the [ __ ] out of it or I hope
they made them stand proof because kids
plan throw Santa its joints is good
because I don't know in Dubai they might
get like a big ass trouble right
it's like super hard
over there from what I hear I think
they're really strict you'll get 50
lashings and a anal intrusions or do
they do public lashings I don't know I
think that's just Singapore couple
glasses are dope oh my gosh Singapore
right for our last story there's this
porn star do you guys know who Aurora
snow is sounds very familiar
they all know who she is Roland oh no
she's blond okay
I've seen her serious I've seen her work
yeah I see the work IT support actually
I'm a fan but you know I know she was a
porn star from 2000 to 2011 Oh she'll
love a new career that's good in a porn
industry [ __ ] beating dude no mom they
usually stop after a year Oh real I saw
documentation oh is it the one it's so
demanding all cuz you got to do like
coke and all kind of drugs do like I
don't know if you gotta do all that but
it's just a really demanding job takes a
lot from your body yeah exactly
this what hold you have to go up the
ranks and [ __ ] yeah I had a friend in
high school who did a make up for porn
set to stuff she was telling me everyone
does coke in high school yeah no I went
to high school with her oh yeah
afterwards I asked her what she was
doing now cuz I met her at the gym
mature though I do makeup for Denver she
was telling all these stories like guys
are on coke and viagra there's a [ __ ]
for four hours do different position
it's like a real film set so my cut iron
Ellen cut we need to redo this come back
over here so you got to stay all horny
and Shivan okay action then so it's like
really really demanding right
that's a terrible job three is getting a
[ __ ] beat up they're just working too
hard so yeah so this rora snow pornstar
she was one of porn biggest celebrities
in that timeframe whoa and so now she's
a journalist and so she'll do like all
of them just oh she could ride to Diane
and I she's a writer and so she
contributes regularly to The Daily Beast
was appoint use no non poor news for
sure okay
so she posted an interview that she did
with her dad over the phone and so her
conversation went like this dad
how did you feel when you heard I was a
horse no silence then came an answer
that blew her
me I was proud Wow whoever saw her
taking that [ __ ] I said that's my
daughter I was soaking because you don't
believe my system music oh no really I
came out on the Howard Stern Show like
on the radio stereo crazy and so I guess
he was making her me like gag sound why
yeah he was just having her jewel that's
us and such a dad was just saying this
interview he'll like that's how you
first found out about her career and
that he was just so angry at Howard
Stern because of what he was making her
do away for 11 [ __ ] me or not 11
years but like for a long time he just
didn't know yeah until that he's mad at
Howard Stern for her life choice no no
for what like subjecting her exactly for
subjecting her on his show
so anyways here just saying that but she
didn't love him or even she exactly yeah
I have to do what the [ __ ] is you
talking well then I was also because how
are Stan was saying that she got into
porn because she had daddy issues then
the dad was like look here's in our life
this is about
yeah she did oh that's true but anyways
besides the point where she ended up
saying as to the reason why she was so
proud of her is because he said when his
friends asked him like way aren't you
like angry that your daughter's a porn
star and he ends up saying like well my
daughter gets paid for sex how much
money have you made having sex none
right then that's his reason as to why
he's proud because she did it on her own
and she runs a successful on her own
because he's saying like he wasn't
really there in her life so well betters
dad is just disgusted I think considered
Setsu and I read that oh no you got and
you know first of all - honey can I just
put this out there I think one adult
says well how much have you made having
sex it makes you sound like a [ __ ]
moral that's how much I mean out of it
yeah so maybe you could have elaborated
all [ __ ] funny
oh my god because he told the truth yeah
he's a Hungarian saying I daddy so those
never there for her
was like I was never there pretty school
for life are you talking about it
something left belong ends up telling
her asleep like like you know I'm not
going to apologize and say that you know
I could have been better because I am
Who I am and then she was like I don't
need you to apologize he's like oh so I
don't have to cry and he sounds like a
[ __ ] [ __ ] he said I was thinking too
much on bad no wonder he's proud so here
your daughter would turn out funny have
you made [ __ ] like alright bro like
on the [ __ ] that is so stupid you're
just trying to look for those oh I told
him moments yeah you could have worded
it just a little bit differently with my
daughter's entrepreneur she had her home
goal and she pursued it yeah many people
out there pursued at home goals yeah and
it could have came off way more
impactful verses well how much does your
daughter suffer many ratable oh I just
wish I was there for her more you know
it's funny like as like this article
started progressing my images and
started morphing yes not growing a
mullet and [ __ ] you started having like
a empty green bottle were you blowing it
oh this thing right here yeah exactly
that's what he was having so she ended
up posting this and then the media just
kind of went with it like what a dad
that's proud of his daughter well yeah
cause he's a [ __ ] loser he doesn't
have anything else to say it would have
been awesome if he was proud before
better reasons he's proud because you
ate well I mean he was saying sort of
what you were saying earlier like you
know she made it on her own like she
worked hard she created whatever she did
for her life so I mean he china was
going there we go absolutely sounds so
stupid it's very odd because like I know
there's a lot of people who talk [ __ ]
about porn you know like oh I can't
believe a thank you for you're the
biggest consumer I don't know if your
dog is on yeah I'll give you like what
you mean you should be thankful yeah
thank you for letting me release on you
I would never talk [ __ ] about ice cream
store you know because I eat ice cream
I'll burn how can you look down on an
ice cream store I think if you want to
have like a solid like strong argument
against it or like anger at least maybe
not you don't have to like it but they
call it like discussing and deplorable
but you know at tomorrow night you're
gonna be jacking off to quit
like it's kind of like I don't know bro
it's like a little hate yeah it's kind
of like this let's say I got fat because
I like this one restaurant so much and
it's greasy and bad but it tastes so
good
I don't blame the food I blame myself
yep so these [ __ ] don't blame
the porn stars blame your Jack offeree
yes I'd be thankful I'm like thank you
because there's no way I could have
access to 50 hot girls in one night
while being a 14-year old child
I want to go on take a news fans hope
you guys liked that episode remember to
follow our personal social media and of
course if you want to watch more videos
my as you go where to go your
[ __ ] right up there
[Music]
you
[Music]